[Music]
my dad was a coolest dad ever man it was
it was a bad kind of cool
he was a guy that would hey dad is it
okay if we go take that fire hydrant
apart so we played water go ahead yeah
it was a speedboat and I asked my dad
can I Drive the boat where did he even
get a speedboat he followed the boat
from a friend so the friend rented the
boat he borrowed the boat from the
friend that rented the boat so nobody
any ownership of this boat I was like
dad can I Drive a boat he's like go
ahead so this is how old I was that man
we went insane and toured a boat up
you're finally going to get a nice
summer you're going off to a summer camp
my dad took me to the wrong to the wrong
camp and left me there all my laughing
yeah I just saw kids outside and I was
like that's it he's I I is that all
right I'll come get you later the story
with your dad bringing home a dog for
you we wanted the dog I've been waiting
for this day day I love you so much
he's like there's gonna be our dog and
he has stole it from like three blocks
up well you described in the book the
woman walks into up there and she said
that's my doggy there was nobody not and
she closed the dog came in the dogs
running tada came Kevin's house was
robbed when he was a kid they didn't
know who robbed the house until they
realized the burglar had come in and
cook grits on the grill burgers like my
dad's favorite dish it opened up the one
drawer I'm in the house where our mom
kept valuable I mean you even say you
don't know whether to laugh or cry you
have to choose a road and I chose the
road I have no resentment toward like oh
is that pot is amazing he's completely
sober now and you know he's focusing on
being an amazing grandfather his actions
now say I know I know how bad I messed
up